all right sigma just announced two new
lenses for the sony e-mount and l-mount
alliance the 90-millimeter f 2.8
i-series contemporary lens and the
24-millimeter f2i series contemporary
lenses how do they perform who are these
lenses for and is sigma starting to
confuse us a little bit with this lens
lineup let's talk about it
now before we kick things off i do want
to let you know we're not paid or
sponsored for this video these are my
thoughts and my thoughts only but big
thanks to sigma singapore for providing
the lenses for review
so let's kick things off let's talk
about the design of the 90 f 2.8 first
because
um this was one of the more surprising
lenses out of the two for me first off
the size it is really compact for a 90
millimeter lens you know normally when
you think 90 you think quite a longer
lens but it is not it is almost getting
into that like a territory or
pseudo-like a territory i should say in
terms of the compactness of it but it is
packing a big punch in what is inside of
it we've got 11 elements in 10 groups
five sld elements and one aspherical
element we've got a nine rounded
diaphragm blades to it it goes from f
2.8 to f 22. the
filter size on this is 55 millimeters
the minimum focusing distance is 50 cm
so this is not a macro lens usually when
you hear 90 f 2.8 you're thinking macro
especially for you sony users out there
this is not a macro lens um now the
diameter on this is slightly different
for the l mount and e mount and i think
it's just basically due to the mount
itself the l mount is slightly shorter
and the sony is slightly longer but by a
couple millimeters not a not a big deal
but the weight of this lens comes in at
295 grams and this lens is an all metal
construction it is beautifully made if
you've never seen the i series
contemporary lenses before this is not
the sigma of years past i mean this is
premium build quality especially for the
price i would say it is hard to find a
lens out there
with this build quality at this price
you just don't i just don't find it i
mean it's made in japan it's all metal
construction the design is gonna you
know it's gonna resemble a little bit of
a cinema lens but it's made for
photographers and videographers in that
sense um and the aperture ring is a nice
click to it
as all sigma lenses have
the focusing ring is just beautiful and
smooth again it's autofocus anyway
you're probably not going to use a
manual focus that much but if you want
to use it you can
and it's just built beautifully and it's
so compact look at this lens
this is really compact um and it packs a
big punch in terms of image quality on
this
at 2.8 it is sharp and that's one of the
things that sigma's doing with this
i-series contemporary lenses they're
trying to keep these lenses as sharp as
possible wide open sort of taking a cue
from leica in that regard which is a
great thing of course when you stop down
most lenses become sharp anyway and they
sort of balance themselves out in terms
of competition but really where you see
the difference in good lenses versus bad
lens is how they perform wide open and
sigma is really concentrating on that
with this i series contemporary lens
lineup and this lens performs
beautifully now it is a little soft in
the corners at a 2.8
but in the center of the frame it is
tack sharp now you will notice that
you're you know you're losing a stop a
light on this so you're going to have to
crank up the iso a little bit more at f
2.8 versus let's say a 1.4 f2 it's not a
deal breaker but obviously depending on
the camera that you're using you may see
more noise creep in especially in lower
light situations but one of the good
things i liked about this lens is
shooting it against backlight subjects
um did a quick test on this with one
image here where you see some of the the
bushes and there's some minimal fringing
there but it is so minimal that you
almost got to zoom in almost
200 to 400 percent to actually see it it
is easily correctable in lightroom or
whatever software that you're going to
use but it's not that bad at all it's
really well corrected so
again hats off for sigma for making a
really nice lens especially the price
point it's a hard lens to say no to it
just depends if you need a 90 f 2.8 lens
that's not a macro lens that is where
it's gonna be interesting okay now let's
talk about the 24 millimeter f2i series
contemporary lens now inside of this
lens you've got 13 elements and 11
groups one fld element two sld elements
and two aspherical elements it is a nine
rounded diaphragm blades f2 to f22 on
the aperture minimal focusing distance
is 24.5 cm
and uh the filter size on this is 62
millimeters now obviously there's gonna
be a difference a slight difference in
the size of the lens in terms of length
because of the mounting on that as i
mentioned before just a couple
millimeters difference on that not a big
deal
uh and the weight the l mount is
slightly heavier coming in at 365 grams
versus 360 grams for the sony e-mount
now
in case you're wondering how it performs
on video this entire review is using the
24f2 to record me right here on a sony
mount camera so you're seeing the
performance it is act sharp eye tracking
is working beautifully it is
a fantastic performing lens in that
regard now both of these lenses because
they're eye series contemporary lenses
they will come with the metal magnetic
lens cover to this now i don't have it
for this review because i opt for the
plastic one because i tend to drop lens
covers sometimes and i don't want to
dent them because or scratch them the
review units and they have to go back to
sigma so i prefer the plastic ones in my
personal opinion anyway just regardless
but they are it's a nice addition to
have
in terms of the image quality coming out
of this lens again tac sharp you can
tell by what's inside of it it is loaded
up with great glass i mean in the center
of the frame it is it is razor sharp
does soften around the corners that have
two of course it does tighten up when
you go to f4 and above that but it is
something to take note of it's not a
deal breaker but you're used to seeing
these with most lenses out there at
their widest aperture sharper in the
center a little softer in the edges
great bokeh in the background fall off
to it it looks really good no issues or
complaints with that and great control
with the chromatic aberration as well i
mean got two spherical elements in this
on all the other great glass so you are
really well controlled in that regard
but the 24 millimeter focal length is an
interesting focal length it's not for
everybody out there some people will
prefer 28 millimeter or they might even
prefer to go wider at 14 or you know 20
or 22. so
it is something that
this will be more of a specialized lens
i think for some people out there but if
you love the 24 millimeter focal length
and you're looking for something a
little bit faster than let's say the 3.5
that sigma launched a number of months
back
also in the i series contemporary lens
lineup then this f2 is a lens i would
definitely uh go for now in terms of
design it has a little bit more
different design than the 90 f 2.8 it
resembles the um 35 f 2 and 65 f 2 i
series contemporary lenses you've got uh
it's got that same sort of metal you
know construction all the way through
you got you have this nice gloss metal
ring that's in the center of it that
sort of differentiates it from that
matte black it just adds a little bit of
lux to the lens it's a beautiful design
lens um
the aperture ring also sounds fantastic
got that nice click to it uh the lens
hood is metal just like the 90 f 2.8 um
it is a solid lens through and through
but this lens does have some heft to it
you know um the you know coming around
360 to 365 grams you are gonna feel it's
not too heavy of course it's not but you
know that this lens screams quality and
i have it here on let's say the uh sigma
fpl i put onto the lumix s1r the sl2
sl2s um even for you sony users out
there for let's say the a7c it's going
to look great on that camera even your
sony let's say
a73 alpha one it'll look good on that as
well it's a really well made lens i have
to say and for the price point again
like the 9df 2.8 it's a hard lens to say
no to
especially if you're looking for this
focal range and this aperture but
yeah
i'm very very uh pleased with how it
performed so let's talk about
this whole conundrum what's going on
with the sigma lenses because this it's
getting a little bit confusing even for
me as a reviewer because these are
considered i series contemporary lenses
in terms of sigma's verbiage these are
you know premium compact prime lenses so
they have that contemporary lens design
with cinema you know lens
design elements in it but it's using
sort of like art glass inside of it so
you're getting really good optics in
this but nowhere on a box or nowhere on
marketing
do you know that this is an i series
lens but they're calling it that so it's
really confusing and they have the c on
it for contemporary so
i wish sigma if you're watching this
video i wish you would differentiate
these lenses a little bit more put an
eye on it you know dress up the box a
little bit different make it something
special out there that when a buyer
knows that an i-series lens in a way is
a step up from the contemporary lens
especially when it comes to optics and i
mean build quality as well it would be a
nice thing to uh to have out there to
really sort of differentiate your lineup
because you have the art series lens
which we know are the creme de la creme
for sigma then you have your sports
lineup which is basically art glass and
a sports lens right and it's durable
it's weather resistant it's meant to be
taken out into harder harsher terrains
the contemporary lenses a lot of people
can consider them to be more of that
budget-friendly lens
but then the i series is supposed to be
luxe but compact prime but you're still
labeling it as a contemporary lens it's
confusing it really is and i hope sigma
does fix this and also it would be nice
to have some sort of lens roadmap out
there so buyers out there if you're
looking for a 24 millimeter lens for
example a number of months back i think
four or five months back or maybe longer
and i forget was the 24 3.5 lens that
was released with the 35 millimeter and
the 65 millimeter f2
very good lens
but then here comes the 24 millimeter f2
so if you were a buyer that you needed a
24 and you bought that lens and now here
comes the f2 you might be like hey wait
a second
ah
why
what happened here why not launch a 24f2
along with these other f2s or give us a
lens roadmap so we have an idea i know
sigma wants to keep things in suspense
sometimes but some of these lenses
aren't going to be like the superstar
lens it's not gonna be like say a 105
1.4
or you know something really you know
exotic and interesting where you want to
keep a little bit of a secret these are
going to be workhorse lenses so it'd be
nice to have that roadmap so at least
buyers and us reviewers for that matter
know what to expect
at least in some way anyway so those are
just my thoughts a little off topic but
a sigma if you're watching maybe clean
up the lens lineup a little bit in terms
of organization it would definitely help
out buyers and reviewers alike so those
are my thoughts on the lenses i really
enjoyed using them uh for the past uh
week or so i've had them they're really
nice build quality is fantastic and if
you're looking for these focal lengths
and the apertures
i mean for the price point it's a hard
lens to say no to my personal opinion
anyway that's it let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below uh
stay safe follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube like this
video it helps out the channel a lot and
i'll talk to you in the next one take
care
you